breaking news the New York Times has
obtained 10 years of President Trump's
tax return information and discovered
wait for it from the late 80s to the
early 90s the president suffered major
business losses which the New York Times
could also have learned if they had read
the entire book that Donald Trump wrote
about that in 1997 or read all of the
tabloid newspapers from the early 90s
that reported on those business losses
were watched even one episode of Trump's
hip network TV show in which he
described at length all of those
business losses we will examine why
mainstream media journalists are the
dumbest people on the face of the earth
all that and more I'm Michel Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
he did it again he did it again and
these stupid gullible people at the New
York Times they took the bait because
they just can't help themselves Rachel
Maddow remember they Trump's tax
information leaked from 2005 big
breaking news and then it turned out he
paid a lot in taxes now he did it again
we will examine this a New York Times
investigation but you know Rees mission
is to make neighborhoods safer and you
probably already know about their smart
video doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere why do you
know about it because I talk about it
all the time because I love my ring
because when you have a ring you feel
like you are living in the Jetsons you
feel like you were living in the future
you can talk to anyone whose rings your
bell goes up to your home you can talk
to them from anywhere in the world if
there's a package delivery if there's a
surprise visitor you will get an alert
you'll be able to see hear and speak to
them all from your phone that's thanks
to the HD video and two-way audio
features on ring devices I love it it
makes me feel safer it makes sweet
little Alisa feel safer our senior
producer Jay hey the other night was
woken up in the middle of the night
because someone ringed his it rang his
doorbell and he pulled out his ring and
he's looking on the camera and it was
these two drug-addled weirdos who were
basically casing the joint trying to see
if anyone was home so they could go rob
him so he said hey why are you here at 3
in the morning and then they ran away
because ring kept his house safe and it
makes me feel safe it'll make you feel
safe as a listener you have a special
offer on a ring starter kit available
right now with a video doorbell and
motion activated floodlight camera or
the starter kit has everything you need
to start building a ring of security
around your home go to ring.com slash
Knowles K no W l es ring com
slash Knowles this was the top trend on
Twitter yesterday this is the moment you
know the left for two years three years
now has been trying to get Donald
Trump's tax returns
he hasn't released them now the New York
Times breaking story and it turns out
what they uncovered is everything that
we have already know
for 35 years now the headline on the New
York Times was decade in the red Trump
tax figures show over 1 billion dollars
in business losses newly obtained tax
information reveals that from 1985 to
1994 Donald J Trump's businesses were in
far bleaker condition than he was
previously known now what they mean is
they were in bleaker condition than was
previously known to the new york times
does anybody who's actually paid
attention to Donald Trump since the 80s
it knew all about this but the New York
Times they finally cracked the cover on
one of trumps books and the gosh oh my
breaking news we've got to run this so
the article begins by the time his
master of the universe memoir Trump the
art of the deal hit bookstores in 1987
Donald J Trump was already in deep
financial distress losing tens of
millions of dollars on troubled business
deals
according to previously unrevealed
figures from his federal income tax
returns the data printouts for mr.
Trump's official IRS transcripts with
the figures from his federal tax form
the 1040 for the years 1985 to 1994
represents the fullest and most detailed
look to date at the president's taxes
information he has kept from the public
view the numbers showed that in 1985 mr.
Trump reported losses of 46 point 1
million dollars from his core businesses
casinos hotels retail space and
apartment buildings they continued to
lose money every year totaling 1.17
billion dollars in losses for the decade
Wow where did they get that from they
might have gotten it from a book called
Trump the art of the comeback which was
published in 1997 by Donald Trump
so they're saying from the mid to late
80s to the early to mid 90s Donald Trump
had major business losses Donald Trump
literally wrote an entire book about
this in the New York Times because they
are so oblivious because they live in
their own little bubble because they are
so desperate not to talk about the
actual news of the day which is evidence
that the real
administration spied on the Trump
campaign because there because of all of
these factors they are running this as
though it is breaking news but what it
this he literally wrote the book on this
the the description of the art of the
comeback is Trump's story begins when
many real-estate moguls went belly-up in
what he calls the Great Depression of
1990 Trump reveals how he negotiated
millions of dollars in bank loans and
survived the recession paving the way
for a resurgence during which he built
the most successful casino in Atlantic
City and this and that and the other
thing in all of his successes it was
published in 97 the the recession hit in
1990 so for real-estate developers who
were a little weak going into 1990 it
took a lot of them out so the premise of
the book is by the late 80s Donald
Trump's business was not doing so hot it
almost went out in 1990 he was like a
billion dollars in debt and then by the
mid 90s he recovered and then he
published the book in 1997 this
timeframe exactly matches the tax
returns that the New York Times appears
to have found but let's say they didn't
read the art of the comeback maybe maybe
the New York Times could have learned
this scintillating bit of information by
watching even one episode of the hit
network TV show that Trump starred in an
executive produced for 12 years my name
is Donald Trump and I'm the largest real
estate developer in New York they owned
buildings all over the place
model agencies the Miss Universe pageant
jetliners golf courses casinos and
private resorts like Mara Lago one of
the most spectacular states anywhere in
the world but it wasn't always so easy
about 13 years ago I was seriously in
trouble I was billions of dollars in
debt but I fought back and I won big
league I used my brain I used my
negotiating skills and I worked it all
out now my company is bigger than it
ever was it's stronger than it ever was
and I'm having more fun than I ever had
[Music]
I've mastered the art of the deal and
had turned the name Trump into the
highest quality brand and as the master
I want to pass along my knowledge to
somebody else I'm looking for the
apprentice it's the old premise of the
show is that Donald Trump had terrible
business performance in the early 90s
and then he came back and fought his way
back that's the whole premise of the
show but just to pay attention here
because well we're making fun of the
mainstream media which I love doing just
remember the the headline of the New
York Times article decade in the red
Trump tax figures show over 1 billion
dollars in business losses for a far
Bleecker condition than was previously
known is what the New York Times writes
you just heard Donald Trump 15 years ago
say that he was billions of dollars in
debt if anything Donald Trump was
exaggerating how bleak his his business
life was in the early 90s the New York
Times spend 1 billion in business losses
he says he was billions in debt and the
New York Times hears that and says we've
uncovered it was far worse than
previously known actually if you'd watch
The Apprentice the conclusion would be
Donald Trump is actually doing a little
better than he was bragging about in the
early 2000s but where else could the New
York Times have heard about this maybe
the New York Times could have heard
about this by reading all of the
newspaper articles when this was
actually happening in New York Post in
1990 Donald Duck's
with a dollar sign for the s defaults on
30 million dollars
creditors ready to pounce another New
York Post headline Saint around the same
time Trump slump again with a dollar
sign because it's the New York Post he's
not a billionaire says Forbes magazine
says net worth nose dives to 500 million
dollars mathematical mistake says the
tycoon so you've got these headlines say
isn't is wealth as nose-diving is not a
billionaire he's losing all of his money
and then Trump is fighting back you say
I'm actually richer than I then you're
saying I am so this has been going on
now for what 30 years the media and
Donald Trump bickering over what
his net worth is Trump saying he's
richer perhaps than he is the media
saying he's poorer than he is now now I
guess this the script has flipped a
little bit now that he's president the
New York Times is trying to to
exaggerate the the scope of his business
losses maybe by the way if even if you
didn't read those newspapers maybe he
didn't watch The Apprentice maybe if you
didn't read that book the art of the
comeback maybe you would have learned
this of trumps major business losses in
1990 in the late 80s in the early 90s by
listening to every one of his critics
for the past thirty years it's not just
the media that are writing about this
not just New York tabloids do you
remember that one of the biggest media
battles of the last 20 years was Donald
Trump versus Rosie O'Donnell how did
that fight begin when Rosie O'Donnell
said this on network television on the
view on ABC you say what you want to say
about me no you said that his father
gave him his money no the fact of the
matter is just say what you want to say
but he's a businessman you know he's all
master of branding there are a lot of
kids have merited money from their
parents and you can't see anything about
it except a car or a house that's him
who we owed money to got shorted out of
the money but he got to again try again
and again and you know what saved him
the second time after his father died
with that money he paid off all his
bankruptcy this is the line of attack
this is the line of attack against Trump
for decades and decades by the way did
you hear Rosie O'Donnell just
contradicted herself she just said he
went bankrupt a bunch of times but he
got out of it he didn't actually have to
pay his debts he just screwed over his
creditors and he made all he made the
little guy pick up the tab but he didn't
pay for it and then not five seconds
later she says and then his father died
and he used that money to pay off all
his debts
so did he pay off his debts or did he
not pay off his debts
did he pay off his debts using his
inherited money or did he screw over his
creditors it can't
both ways but the media want to have it
both ways they want Donald Trump to be
this billionaire plutocrat who's a
corrupt and he's made all of his money
and he's cheated the system and they
wanted to be a total loser they want him
to not have that much money at all and
they're trying to advance these
arguments at the same time and by the
way the way they're doing it is is
bringing up information that has been so
public for the last 30 years that Trump
himself has made it a key part of his
own narrative so who leaked it that's
the other question who leaked these
documents you'll notice in the article
it says breaking investigative New York
Times and it's got these two authors
that I haven't really heard of and then
at the very bottom of the article it
says Maggie Haberman contributed
reporting very little note at the bottom
a lot of people didn't pick up on this
Maggie Haberman you might remember is
one of the favored journalists for the
Democrat Party it's you can't even
really call her a journalist at this
point because she just carries water for
the Democrats there was a 2015 strategy
document from the Hillary Clinton
campaign that got leaked it described
Haberman as a friendly reporter it said
that the Hillary campaign always used
her to tee up stories for them and that
they were never disappointed by her
coverage so where did this come from I
don't know that little note at the
bottom Maggie Haberman contributed
reporting does seem to give away a lot
of the story now when I saw this last
night this was the breaking news on
Twitter I could not stop laughing if you
were following the the whole show on
Twitter last night I just could not stop
laughing about this because I just
thought these journalists are the
stupidest people on earth only
mainstream media journalists could be so
oblivious could get so whipped up in
their frenzy of hatred for the president
that they could cover a story that they
think is going to attack the president
and actually ends up totally destroying
their own credibility
I wondered I'm not sure I mean maybe
this is a little too clever by half
I wondered if Donald Trump leaked these
tax documents himself
seriously because it you'll remember a
year or two ago Rachel Maddow had this
big breaking news exclusive we have
Donald Trump's 2005 tax return we're
gonna open it we're gonna find out that
he didn't pay any taxes and oh he paid
38 million dollars in taxes that year
okay never mind and she almost cried on
air she was so upset and this at the
time I just thought man Trump and his
campaign just destroy the media they
play these guys like a fiddle then fast
forward now almost any period of Donald
Trump's tax returns could be used to
hurt him if they got his two returns
from the 70s or the early 80s maybe the
early 2000s kind of before The
Apprentice really took off I don't know
just coincidentally they were only able
to get his tax returns from the exact
period of time that he always brags
about losing money it's it's a boast at
this point that he wrote a book about
did a TV show about they get just that
exact amount of time it seems almost too
perfect and so what are the conclusions
of the documents the conclusions are for
a little under a decade Donald Trump
paid a low tax rate when when you take
into account losses deductions all these
sort of things he basically didn't pay
he didn't he didn't have a tax liability
so the the charitable view of that is
that Donald Trump took major business
losses we know there was a huge downturn
in New York real estate at that time we
know that the tax code was was favorable
toward real estate developers to where
people who were building things so that
seems pretty fair the unshare
double-reed of that document is that
Donald Trump cheated on his taxes that
he paid a rate that was too low but this
one is kind of hard to believe because
Donald Trump is under audit currently I
believe and he certainly was under audit
two years ago this is a very wealthy guy
with a lot of business interests who has
been audited so if if he really
underpaid on taxes one would expect that
that would already be discovered by now
now what's another takeaway another
takeaway is that Donald Trump had less
money than he said he did for many years
duh yeah of course uh where have you
been
yeah of course this has always been the
knock on Trump is that he brags about
having more money than he does so is
that news is that that the New York
Times thinks this is a big story
they've been lobbying this attack on him
for three years much more than three
years then you got to wonder what do the
Democrats get out of this first of all
nobody cares about Donald Trump's taxes
nobody cares about any politicians taxes
this is just an attack that has come up
over the past few decades too for
opposition research firms to launch more
assaults on other candidates nobody
cares public opinion shows this people
care about immigration they care about
jobs they care about the economy they do
not care about the tax returns of some
politician from ten years ago we have
too much to do we got too much on our
minds this does not really matter now
what else do Democrats get from this
they they now get to highlight how
Donald Trump fought his way back from a
billion dollars of debt a billion
dollars of losses is that bad
Democrats get now to push the narrative
that Trump has tried to push for 30
years people like that it exposes a lot
of the elitism of the mainstream media
when this came out one of the trends
that was going on on Twitter was they
said Donald Trump shouldn't have hosted
The Apprentice he should have hosted the
Biggest Loser ha ha ha they're making
fun of Trump because he took some big
risks in business and had some big
losses and then made a lot of his money
back first of all does anyone actually
believe Donald Trump is not a wealthy
man right now I know some people try to
say that say he's not as rich as he says
he is okay fine certainly we all can
agree Donald Trump is a very wealthy man
right now and has been for at least I
don't know the last 15 years so what the
New York Times do they say ha ha he
wasn't a billionaire for 10 years
oh yes ah Jeeves Jeeves pour me a little
more pork please we're making fun of how
Donald from Queens you know he has that
outer borough accent he
wasn't even a billionaire for the early
90s
this is how we're going to win votes
from those plebeians in New York City
bah no I mean that that's what they are
they're portraying themselves as rich
uncle Pennybags over here they're
portraying themselves as the guy on the
monopoly box not not a good way to
connect to the American people totally
botched hit whoever leaked it really
does seem to have backfired here and I
don't know I mean I like to think that
it was Republicans who leaked this
document because it's a great troll and
you know at this moment in time
Republicans are really good at trolling
the media and Democrats if it wasn't the
Republicans who leaked this if it wasn't
Trump himself for so some but if it
wasn't like kind of a media dirty hit if
this actually was leaked from the
government this is a major crime to leak
someone's private tax return information
is a very serious crime
so certainly an investigation should
take place and whoever is responsible
for it should be held to account unless
it was you know unless it was Trump
himself who whoever actually committed a
crime of stealing this information
should be held to account this is really
bad I mean we attack WikiLeaks for
hacking into the the government and you
know releasing information that should
not be released and rightly so how is
this that much different you have
somebody going into our federal
government stealing information leaking
it to the media and publishing it to
damage not only a politician not only a
candidate but the President of the
United States that's a big deal that's a
very big deal moving on over to Georgia
we got some very good news in Georgia as
well Governor Brian Kemp just signed a
bill that will ban abortions if a
heartbeat can be detected in the baby so
this means it could be as early as six
weeks
this is excellent news and there look
there have been many restrictions on
abortion over the last ten years
and they're all good this one is
especially good and the left is super
angry over this Hollywood threatened to
boycott pull all of its film industry
out of Georgia because of this potential
bill that you've had celebrities
constantly ranting about it giving
speeches going on social media about it
why the left is so angry about this
Georgia bill because it is extremely
consequential this law it's being
referred to as the heartbeat law this
law gives away the whole abortion
argument why it says that you cannot
abort your baby after a heartbeat has
been detected now why a heartbeat does
ah is a heartbeat what makes you a human
I don't know her I mean heart's a very
important organ but it's just an organ
why not a brain stimulation why not
fingernails why not a nose why not the
features of a face the reason it's a
heartbeat is because we associate in
just in our minds in our culture we
associate the heartbeat with life we
associate the heartbeat with the essence
of what it is to be a human little
clumps of cells don't have heartbeats
random piles of DNA don't have heart
beats what has a heartbeat a baby has a
heartbeat if you can't have an abortion
after a baby has a heartbeat that means
that the baby has a heartbeat and if the
baby has a heartbeat then the baby is a
baby that's why this is so consequential
it's it's a very good law because it
both pulls on the heartstrings literally
I guess it pulls on it gives us this
image the heart what is a heart the
heart is human life and it takes
abortion to its logical conclusion we
all agree everybody listening agrees
that you shouldn't be able to kill a
baby a day after he's been born
right we all agree on them we all agree
you shouldn't be able to kill a baby as
he's being born you know 10 hours prior
well if that those two things are true
you probably shouldn't be able to kill a
baby a day
before he's about to be born I mean has
the baby really change a day before he's
gonna be born to the day he's born no
how about a week before he's born it's
the same baby about a month before he's
born same baby four months before he's
born it's the same baby now further and
further back the baby stops resembling a
baby as much doesn't have fully formed
features so it just in our in our minds
not an objective reality but in our
imperfect perception of things we see
the early stage baby and we say oh it
doesn't look totally like a baby so I
guess we can kill it but now we go all
the way back we get to six weeks or
eight weeks this is pretty early in a
pregnancy month and a half two months
and we say but even that little thing
which doesn't totally look like a baby
has a heartbeat gosh I guess it's wrong
to kill a baby at all not just 220 weeks
not just 26 weeks I guess it's wrong at
all the left is furious over this aoc of
course objected she tweeted out one of
the coldest things I have ever seen
tweeted which is really saying something
she tweeted out quote six weeks pregnant
equals two weeks late on your period I
guess that's true kind of missing the
point a one-month old newborn baby lying
in its crib equals 40 weeks late on your
period that is not to say that the sum
total of what a one-month old newborn
baby is is just yeah I'm just 40 weeks
late on my period huh likewise a six
weeks old baby unborn baby it's not just
a missed period a six weeks old unborn
baby is not just a little morning
sickness a six weeks old unborn baby is
not just a little bump starting to form
in your belly six weeks old unborn baby
is a baby a OC goes on typical
demagoguery
most of the men writing these bills
don't know the first thing about a
woman's body outside of the things they
want from it it's relatively common for
a woman to have a late period and not be
pregnant so this is a backdoor ban it's
not a backdoor ban it's a baby it's not
a clump of cells it's a baby because I
also love most of the men writing these
bills don't know anything about a
woman's body well what about the men who
support abortion rights what about a
governor Ralph Northam in Virginia who
said it we should be able to kill babies
after they've been born does he know
about a woman's body what about Andrew
Cuomo who now in New York it's now
illegal to kill a baby as it's being
born he signed that law does does he
know about a woman's body it's there so
selective with their sexual
discrimination here they say men can't
say anything about abortion unless they
support it in which case great sign all
the laws you want but the whole point is
ridiculous just because I am a man
doesn't mean I can't understand aspects
of womanhood and you know why because I
have a brain and I have faculties of
reason so I can reason through things
and I have evidence and I have the
scientific method and I have all sorts
of resources at my disposal just because
a doctor hasn't had cancer doesn't mean
a doctor can't operate on cancer just
because I've never been to Tahiti
doesn't mean I can't form a picture of
what Tahiti looks like I can't read
about Tahiti I can't look at a
photograph of Tahiti of course the men
signing these bills voting for these
bills and the women voting for these
bills understand what is at stake and
what is at stake is not six weeks of
pregnancy what is at stake is a baby of
course the the left won't concede this
and you had a man not a woman a man
Chris Cuomo on CNN who was moderating
one of the stupidest panels on abortion
I have ever seen but it shows you a
desperate the left is they've lost this
argument and they are steadily losing
this argument and so they get shriller
and shriller and shrill and we'll get to
it in a second then our old buddy in
Philadelphia Brian Simms that wacko
weirdo hello
representative there who who stalks
little teenage girls and elderly women
at Planned Parenthood he issues a fake
apology and will get to all of that in a
second but I've got a second by to
Facebook and YouTube go to daily
wire.com
it is ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me get the
Andrew Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the mount wall show
you had to ask questions in the mailbag
you a mail bags fine coming up tomorrow
by the way so get your questions in you
get another Kingdom you get the leftist
ears tumblr by the way tomorrow I am
going to be in Missouri I was invited by
state senator Eric Burleson there to
give a speech at the State Capitol
Missouri on the importance of free
speech on campus this was after I was
physically assaulted at the University
of Missouri Kansas City after an invited
speech there and that was after the
chancellor of that university instead of
condemning the assailants and the
hecklers he condemned me as some sort of
bigot and smeared me and did not stand
for free speech or liberal education so
I'm going to go to the State Capitol
tomorrow and call for that man's
resignation and his firing and a
vigorous defense of free speech on
campus so if you're in Jefferson City
Missouri come on out it should be a good
time otherwise I'll see you on the show
at Daily wire calm because you will need
the leftist here's tumblr as we bring
free speech back to Missouri go to daily
wire calm we'll be right back with a lot
more
so Chris Cuomo yesterday on CNN was
moderating a panel between a debate
between Rick Santorum former GOP
presidential candidate and Senator and
Christine Quinn Christine Quinn was New
York City Council she ran for mayor
there this woman was almost the mayor of
New York and she gives the shrillest
stupidest defense of abortion
maybe that I've ever heard here is the
panel woman gets pregnant that is not a
human being
inside of her it's part of her body and
this is about a woman having full agency
and control of her body and making
decisions about her body and what is
part of her body with medical
professionals listen so at least
Christine Quinn is not making the
argument that the baby is not a human
therefore it's a platypus the baby is
not a human therefore it's a giraffe no
baby you see it's it's human but what
she says is it's not an individual human
that's not a separate human it's just
part of the woman's body now this is
demonstrably false the baby has
individual DNA the baby doesn't grow
organically out of the woman's body the
baby is conceived by the combination of
the woman's egg in the man's sperm so
another human being has to come together
in an act of love or I don't know an act
of drunken revelry come together with
the woman and conceive this baby which
then grows in the woman but is separate
from the woman genetically distinct
physically distinct and then of course
will be born unless someone like
Christine Quinn kills it in the womb so
if the baby growing in the mother's womb
were just a part of her body then it
would probably be pretty weird when that
baby is born and starts running around
on its own
I'd be that'd be pretty that would make
us like starfish or octopuses or
something you know with a starfish it
cut off one of its little legs and then
it just grows another starfish you said
gosh that's pretty that would basically
humans would become starfish
if that were true go don't try this at
home but imagine if you just went out
and you cut off your arm you said oh my
gosh what's how do I cut off my arm no
no don't worry it's okay it'll just grow
another person that's it's just you know
it'll just grow another person and run
around that's what happens with babies
and babies are just part of the mother's
body except the babies not part of the
mother's body it's a separate body now
she then goes on [ __ ] so she stops
making this stupid argument which is
going nowhere and then gets to the real
question is it okay you're not you're
asking provocative things that are
trying to make the people angry what's
done and that's okay so Chris Cuomo is
just don't know Chris Cuomo is just not
fit morally or intellectually for this
conversation so he's just rambling
nonsense Rick Santorum raises a great
question here this is a brilliant
question that a lot of times you don't
really hear in pro-life advocacy what
Christine O'Donnell says is the the baby
is part of the mother's body therefore
you can kill it that's kind of a weird
argument to make by the way my my arm is
part of my body can I kill my arm first
of all I literally can't kill my arm you
can't kill it you can sever it and then
the all of the cells will die but it's
not like I can kill my arm I can't abort
my arm but even if even if you could
even if that were were conceptually
possible would you suggest that would
you so it's part of your body therefore
cut it off and chop it up and kill it
know if it's part of your body you
probably want to preserve it because
it's part of your body so so Rick
Santorum sees the flaw in this argument
here and he says okay Christine you
can't hear it over Chris Cuomo stupid
yapping same with Christine O'Donnell or
Christine Quinn but what Rick Santorum
says is okay whatever that baby is
whatever you want to call the baby if
you can kill it because it's morally
insignificant it's more
irrelevant if you can kill that baby
then you can do anything to it right and
then Christine Quinn says something to
the effect of and so you just have to
try to tune that ad because it's so
grating on your ears but follow Rick
Santorum's logic if you can kill the
baby then surely you can torture it
right what why if you're if you're able
to murder it surely you can go in and
kind of poke it around and maybe mess up
its brain cells a little bit it's
morally irrelevant it doesn't matter
don't know don't worry it's not a human
you can so you can torture it it's fine
why is it okay to kill an unborn baby
but it's not okay to torture an unborn
baby now the real answer is because even
pro-abortion supporters have some
intuition on some gut level that that
baby has moral significance and the
reason that they are willing to kill it
is not because of some real
philosophical conviction that it doesn't
matter but because it's convenient and
they don't want to be parents and they
don't want to deal with the consequences
of their actions and they don't want to
even give up their baby for adoption in
the United States thirty six couples
waiting for every American baby that is
born and put up for adoption thirty six
couples waiting for everyone baby born
and put up for adoption there plenty of
people waiting to adopt your baby but
you don't want to put the baby up for
adoption why because maybe it's
uncomfortable for nine months and and
more importantly because you don't want
to give up your kid because there's a
part of us deep deep down our conscience
that says I don't want to give up my kid
and parents who decide to give up their
kid rather than kill it they're making a
heroic and courageous decision but the
cowardly decision and decision that
Christine Quinn is trying to defend is
to just kill it because lalalalala I
mean actually the way that she's holding
this debate is indicative of the
argument about abortion because if you
just have a calm and collected argument
about abortion which is what Rick
Santorum is doing what that probably
means is that you've thought about this
and you're confident your opinion but if
you're just saying a lot of
contradictory and emotional and untrue
things about a bad abortion then
probably instead of having a cool and
collected discussion where you let your
other your debate partner get in his
points what you have to do is just
scream and shout and lalalalala I can't
hear you I can't hear you
which is what Christine Quinn is doing
no you can't torture the baby why can't
you torture the baby why is it wrong to
torture the baby because it's a baby
therefore it's also wrong to kill the
baby and here's where Chris Cuomo has to
come in because Chris Cuomo has a
personal stake here
Chris Cuomo's brother Andrew Cuomo is
the governor of New York and he just
ratified and celebrated one of the most
radical abortion laws in the country
this abortion law legalizes killing
babies as they are being born and it
actually changes the Penal Code such
that if a guy goes up and kills a
pregnant woman in the old days he would
be charged with double murder but now
after andrew cuomo's abortion law he'll
only be charged with a single murder
because that pert little protection for
the baby was taken away so Chris Cuomo
has a lot at stake here he swoops in to
try to make the argument and it fails
what's done and that's okay
all I'm saying is you guys go too far
when you pervert the facts we have the
president of united states saying that a
baby is born at the end of full-term
swaddled in a blanket and then they
decide whether or not to execute it you
know that yes it divides people nobody
said it it's not the law anywhere in
this country
it's homicide one person said something
stupid and you want to make it something
that you can use their advantage that
doesn't help your thought so did you see
Chris Cuomo just contradicted himself
because he said nobody in this country
has ever called for a baby who has been
born to be killed do you know it's BS
rick santorum you nobody has called for
that rick santorum very calmly says
Ralph Northam the Democrat governor of
Virginia not just an activist not just a
congressman not just a state
representative the governor of Virginia
explicitly called for that on the radio
here it is they are
you know when we talk about third
trimester abortions these are done with
the consent of obviously the the mother
with the consent of the physicians more
than one physician by the way and it's
done in cases where there may be severe
deformities there may be a fetus that's
non Bible so in this particular example
if a mother is in labor I can tell you
exactly what would happen the infant
would be delivered the infant would be
kept comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mothers did you hear
that if the baby is born maybe he's got
some deformities maybe it's kind of ugly
I don't know maybe it comes out not
looking the way you wanted to look so
then the baby would be kept comfortable
maybe resuscitated if you know he had
some problems and maybe the mother
wanted him to be resuscitated and then
then once the baby has been resuscitated
sitting there on the table swaddled and
clothing then the doctor and the mother
would talk about whether or not to kill
it governor of Virginia said this so
Chris Cuomo says nobody ever said that
then Rick Santorum says the governor of
Virginia did and Chris Cuomo says okay
one guy said it okay yeah one right one
major American political figure of your
political party said that and Rick
Santorum held back here because what he
really should have said is actually
Chris your brother Andrew Cuomo in New
York is leading the charge this is that
this is the law lest you think that I'm
being unfair here this is the law in New
York it permits abortion when according
to a medical professional it is quote
reasonable a medical professionals quote
reasonable and good-faith professional
judgment based on the facts of the
patient's case and when the patient is
within 24 weeks from the commencement of
pregnancy so legal abortion in the first
24 weeks okay that's true virtually
everywhere but listen to this part or
there is an absence of fetal viability
what is fetal viability I mean does it
mean the baby's actually dead it doesn't
mean the baby's probably he's got some
condition it means he probably won't
survive very long he won't live very
long how long how old will you live - -
he'll live - three I don't know and then
listen to this or when the abortion is
necessary to protect the patient's life
okay so this is also the law in a lot of
places if the mother's life is at risk
you can have an abortion now there are
virtually no case in which an abortion
is the remedy to save a mother's life
there are some cases in which treating
the mother's condition will kill the
baby as a consequence of that but there
there is virtually no condition in which
the abortion is the solution that's the
medical solution to saving the mother's
life but then listen to this last word
that Devils in the details or the
abortion is necessary to protect the
patient's life or health and health here
this is the big floodgate because health
is being described not just in terms of
your physical health but your mental
health your psychological health your
financial health anything as long as you
get a little doctor's note that says
yeah it's gonna be really detrimental to
Susie's feelings if she has this baby
you can kill that baby in the state of
New York thanks to Chris Cuomo was
brother Andrew up until the moment he is
born that is what Christine Quinn is
defending that is what Chris Cuomo is
defending and that is what our good
buddy over in Pennsylvania that state
representative Brian Sims is defending
when he goes and stalks teenage girls
and tries to Doc's teenage girls and
tries to to harass and demean and mock
elderly women in who were just
protesting outside of Planned Parenthood
there that's what he is defending so
Brian Sims one of the schmucky espanha
merica he has just been eviscerated in
the press and on social media in the
right-wing press for those videos that
he's been posting that we've played over
the last couple days now the by the way
the CNN is it not written about him
CNN wrote a story about a positive story
about him a few
years ago so it's not like they won't
talk about this guy in the state
representative they have not covered
Brian Sims at all
Brian Sims one of the hottest news
stories in the country right now but
they have to cover it up because they
have to carry water not only for
Democrats but specifically for defenders
of abortion Brian Sims of his own accord
released a apology video yesterday on
his social media account now see if you
can figure out which word is missing
from his apology video hi everyone
representative Brian Sims here and I'm
actually up in our Capitol for this
week's legislative session but I stepped
off the floor for a moment because I've
received a lot of feedback about a video
I posted last week and I want to provide
some background you see I've lived
across the street or next door to this
particular Planned Parenthood where the
most heavily protested Planned
Parenthood's in America for the last 15
years I've seen men and women and teens
try to go there for routine health care
for checkups for pap smears for breast
exams for STD screenings and yes for
abortions in fact it's where I even
treat for my own life-saving prep
medication and I'm grateful for the
services that they provide I've also
spent the last seven years serving as a
volunteer patient escort at this Planned
Parenthood and I have seen firsthand the
insults the slurs the attacks and the
racism that those protestors and mostly
young girls going there for clinical
care care that those of us on the
outside can never understand and last
week was no different I fully understand
respect and appreciate the
non-engagement policy that they have and
I would never want to do anything that
interferes with the care that they're
providing to their patients as an
activist and an advocate I know why
pushing back against harassment and
discrimination or a must even when
they're uncomfortable but last week I
wasn't a patient escort I was a neighbor
and a concerned citizen and I was
aggressive I know that two wrongs don't
make a right and I can do better and I
will do better for the women of
Pennsylvania did you catch which word
was missing from that apology sorry
sorry was missing another word that was
missing is apologize because he's not
apologizing he's defending his actions
so he begins
by saying that the people who protest
abortion who protest the killing of
children are bigots he accuses them of
racism somehow Planned Parenthood kills
three times as many black babies as it
does white babies more black babies in
New York City are killed in the womb
than are born in the most dangerous
place for a black person in New York is
in his mother's womb and he accuses
those of us who don't want to kill all
of those black babies of racism so
that's how he starts now why does he do
this then this does underline a pretty
eternal truth of leftism a pretty
eternal truth of political debate when a
leftist calls you a racist you know
you've won the argument that's all they
can do that's all this coward bully
schmuck can do is pretend to be a victim
and then he defends Planned Parenthood
defends killing babies defends his
actions his aggression defends stalking
and daxing underage girls defends
harassing and mocking and ridiculing an
elderly woman and then that's his
apology well I'm going to Philadelphia
this Friday because my friend and
colleague Matt Walsh launched a major
pro-life rally there that's going to
take place at the plant Planned
Parenthood in Philadelphia the same one
that this guy stalks the same one that
this guy volunteers at because he's just
so so covetous of abortions he's just so
desirous he has such a hunger that more
babies be killed that he volunteers his
time to walk women in and encourage them
to kill their children and then in his
free time when he's not volunteering
there he goes and harasses the underage
girls and elderly women and intimidates
them and threatens them and DOCSIS them
so I'm going to go there to this
wonderful pro-life rally on Friday I
hope if you're in the area you come on
out and Brian Sims I hope you come on
out I think you won't because you're a
coward
and because Brian Sims can't pick on
someone his own size he's got to stick
to stalking young underage teenage girls
and elderly women he thinks that's
that's a fight that he's more more able
to win but I hope he comes out look
forward to seeing him there I look
forward to
seeing all of you in the meantime I'll
be in Missouri if you're in Jefferson
City come on out to that speech tomorrow
at the State Capitol and I'll also see
you on the show in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show see them the Michael Noel's show is
produced by Rebecca dabka wits and
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy Borah senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
Audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jeshua alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show the New York
Times is writing about the fact that
Donald Trump was in debt in the 80s
which no one has ever written about
before except for Donald Trump the New
York Times is writing about anything it
can to keep from writing about the one
thing it doesn't want to face Barack
Obama was an incompetent and corrupt
president
I'm Andrew Clavin we'll talk about it
all on the Andrew Clavin show